foreign
[Music]
service accounts represent non-human
users there are special kinds of
accounts intended for scenarios where an
application or a workload needs to
access resources or perform actions such
as making authorized API calls Without
End user involvement let's get started
with when to use service accounts use
service accounts for unattended
scenarios when an unattended application
such as a batch job or a resource
monitoring agent needs to access a
resource it must act on its own and not
on behalf of end users create a service
account for the application and granted
access to just the resources the
application needs doing so restricts the
scope of what the application can access
while attributing the resource access to
the application itself service accounts
are also useful for applications in
which a user authenticates with a custom
authentication scheme and then
indirectly accesses Google Cloud
resources the application should confirm
that the user's authentic educated and
authorized then use a service account to
authenticate to a Google Cloud resource
do not use service accounts to access
user data without the user's consent an
application might require access to
sensitive or personal user data use the
oauth consent flow to request the end
user's consent and then let the
application act under the end user's
identity
this ensures that end users can review
which resources they're about to Grant
the application access to and can
explicitly Express or deny their consent
users can revoke their consent at any
time for more information on the oauth
consent flow check out this
documentation
service accounts support different types
of authentication methods
let's now look at the best practices to
choose the right authentication method
when using a service account based on
your use case
for applications running on Google Cloud
use attached service accounts when
possible this enables the application to
obtain tokens to access Google cloud
apis and resources for applications
using gke use workload identity to
attach service accounts to kubernetes
pods this creates a mapping between the
service account and their corresponding
kubernetes service accounts for more
information on workload identity check
out this documentation if your
application runs on another cloud
provider or on premises and you have
access to environmental specific
credentials use workload identity
Federation for more information on
workload identity Federation check out
this documentation when there's no
viable alternative use service account
Keys use organization policy constraints
to limit key usage and rotate the keys
frequently now let's look at some past
practices for managing service accounts
follow a naming and documentation
convention for example sample Add a
prefix and the name of the application
to the service account email address
that identifies its usage create single
purpose service accounts manage the
service account and the associated
Service as one unit and apply the same
processes and life cycle to them if you
have to use service account Keys rotate
them often the more often you rotate
service account Keys the less likely it
is that a leaked service account key is
still valid when a bad actor finds it
disable unused service accounts to
reduce the risk of a service account
being abused by a bad actor disable the
service account not being used anymore
disable unused service accounts before
deleting them to avoid inadvertently
losing IEM bindings it's best to disable
the service account when it's not needed
anymore and only delete it after a
certain period has elapsed for more
information on best practices
authentication methods and when to use
service accounts check out this
documentation thanks for watching
foreign
[Music]